Regarding the cheek swab test, if you can say what would cause a need to increase turmeric to the smoothie, in other words, what are we treating by increasing the turmeric?
So understand what I do at cheek swab test. Sometimes people go, how come you took that out? How come you told me to stop this or how come you reduce that from 4 a day to 2 a day?
Or then how come you increased this one from 2 a day to 4 a day? So in the cheek swab testing, I'm just reading what's coming out when I'm doing the test.
Now I could try to understand that from a physiological standpoint, metabolic standpoint, to go, well, why would we increase turmeric?
Why would we decrease this product? Well, we might decrease the product because your body is saturated with it. You don't need anymore to that. We might increase the product because you need more of the benefits that that product does.
What does turmeric do in the body? Well, turmeric in itself can be a cancer killer directly.
I bet you, I bet you there's a thousand articles on Google, maybe a thousand pages of articles on Google about the benefits of turmeric for cancer.
I'm not exaggerating. So whoever turmeric is currently mid. So doing, so increasing turmeric for cancer patients can be cancer killing the direct cancer killer.
In general, for a non-cancer patient, what's the benefits of turmeric? It's an anti-inflammatory. So it's a flammatory and it's going to decrease inflammation. So you can say turmeric is good for everybody.
Certainly good for great inflammation. Certainly good for just over body inflammation. So it's whatever came up on the test, doesn't mean that some people go, well, you had me increase this.
This set me up doing worse. No, it doesn't. I'm not quantitatively saying a person is doing better or worse. It's just telling me what your body needs.